again this week breaking news there at
least seven people are dead after
missile strikes
on the city of la vie but despite this
attack in the west of ukraine russia
appears to be shifting its focus to the
east
now this map shows the territory that
russia occupied about three weeks ago
including areas near the capital city of
kiev here's what they control today as
you can see the russian troops are now
concentrated mostly in the eastern and
southern parts of the country and that's
where fierce battle is still raging for
the southern port city of mariupol which
has been mostly destroyed president
zielinski vows ukrainians will fight
absolutely to the end to defend the city
charlie dagida is in ukraine charlie
good morning
good morning ukraine's prime minister
said forces there continue to make a
stand in mary opal and they will do
until the end this despite renewed
threats from russian forces that any
remaining fighters will be eliminated we
need to point out that this report
contains images that some might find
disturbing
there's not much left of mario pole
after weeks of an unrelenting russian
onslaught but within this sprawling
steel plant and the series of tunnels
beneath it a number of ukrainian forces
are still holding out defying the
ultimatum from russia to surrender or
die
ukraine's foreign minister dimitro
kuleba told face the nation russia is
raising the city to the ground at any
cost the situation in mariupol is both
dire militarily and heartbreaking
the city doesn't exist anymore
medics treating an injured woman were
forced to die for cover to save their
own lives in the middle of an artillery
attack
amid the suffering and fear worshipers
gathered for the start of holy week in
ukraine easter is celebrated next sunday
in venezia southwest of the capital
proto-deacon vladislav prayed for the
lives of the injured and the souls of
the dead
but the war has turned a church into a
battleground too
after russian orthodox leaders gave
their blessings to the war and president
putin too
father vladislav says that makes the
russian orthodox church an accomplice
it's a position no church should ever
take he said russia started this war not
defending their territory but attacking
the territory of our country
even as the war rages on he's praying
for peaceful easter
is it more difficult to hope under the
circumstances
when people undergo all this grief and
atrocities and they still hope still
believe still say they feel the hand of
god that guides them this belief becomes
their reality
and new images have emerged of that
russian warship that went down in the
black sea last week the moskva take a
look at this yet smoke billowing and
starting to sink shortly after allegedly
being struck by ukrainian missiles now
naval experts have identified that that
is the ship but it can't be confirmed
where or when those images were taken
the kremlin can insist continue to
insist that it went down by accident
vlad
still a lot of questions there charlie
and of course we around the world join
the deacon in praying for the lives of
the injured and the souls of the dead
charlie dagged in ukraine thank you very
much